[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID AUERBACH:
Thanks for hosting me.
I realized I should
probably just cover
my history for anyone
who didn't know it.
I grew up in the 1980s
programming in Logo.
I learned how to
do the triangles.
I learned how to do the turtles.
Can I actually just
get a show of hands?
Who here has programmed in Logo?
That's amazing.
You know, I spoke at a business
conference the other day.
No one raised their hands.
I said, OK, who here
is programmed in LISP?
No one.
I said, who here
has heard of LISP?
No one.
[LAUGHTER]
It was like, wow, it's just
all R and Python these days.
So, yeah, so I grew up on Logo.
In the '90s, my wife
and I-- who is here--
majored in computer science.
And we worked at Microsoft.
And I'm going to be
talking a bit about that.
And then after a couple
of years at Microsoft,
we came to Google.
We were here and I
was here in the 2000s.
And I worked on the
web mirror team,
which was part of
the crawl back then.
And because I was
a little crazy,
I decided to give it up and
become a writer and critic
and technologist.
And this is sort of
the result, my book.
And but it's really
good to be back.
I mean, we were on the
fourth floor back then.
And this brings back
a lot of memories.
So this has a special
meaning for me.
So I was going to read
a couple sections that,
hopefully, are relevant to
more computer-oriented people.
But first, as proof
of my bona fides,
you may notice that
it's called "Bitwise."
And those are actual
bitwise operators
on the cover, something
I made sure of so
that people would
say, no, I just
didn't look in a library
of computer terms
and picked one
that sounded cool.
The real discovery though
was this bit of art
by Richard McGuire.
He's a cartoonist who does
some "New Yorker" covers.
And if you noticed the
pipe and the ampersand,
those are indeed
bitwise operators.
And I was very happy to find
that piece of art and use it.
So the first part I'd
like to speak about is--
this is actually a tale
of my time at Microsoft.
And bizarrely enough,
we have someone here
who was actually there at the
time on the very same team.
So he can verify that I'm
not embellishing this.
And this section is
called "Chat Wars."
And it begins with a
quote from Grace Hopper,
"It's easier to ask forgiveness
than it is to get permission."
And now you'll see why.
[LAUGHS]
At 22, when I was just
out of college and still
a green software
engineer, I thought
America Online and AOL won.
The battle made the front
page of the "New York Times."
The public was beginning
to care about code.
This wasn't the code
that would crack
the secrets of mathematics or
the nature of the universe,
but it was the lifeblood
of our economy and society.
It was the summer
of 1999, and people
were starting to realize
that the internet and the web
were becoming a new
dynamic circulatory
system for informations,
coordination, and life itself.
The summer before my
final year of college,
I interned as a
software engineer
at Microsoft in Redmond.
I was assigned to
the group that was
building MSN Messenger Service,
Microsoft's instant messaging
app.
And after receiving my degree, I
went on to join them full time.
The unwieldy name was cooked
up by Microsoft's marketing
department which had a
reputation for always picking
the clunkiest and least
imaginative product
names: Buddy List, C
U C Me, MSN Messenger.
No, it was MSN
Messenger Service,
but I'll call it
"Messenger" for short.
At the time, the big
players in instant messaging
were AOL Instant
Messenger, Yahoo, and ICQ.
AOL Instant Messenger--
AIM for short--
had tens of millions of users.
AOL had become the
country's biggest dial-up
provider in the mid '90s
by blitzing mailboxes
with CD-ROMs.
And all AOL users
automatically became AIM users.
Yahoo and ICQ each
had millions of users.
These are paltry numbers
by the standards of 2018,
but they were
meaningful in the '90s.
After my team finished
developing the client code,
we had some downtime while
waiting for the server team
to finish their
Hotmail integration.
We couldn't release
without their work.
We fixed every
bug we could find.
One of the problems
was getting new users
to join Messenger when
so many people already
used other chat programs.
Unlike email, which
has the standard SMTP
format across all programs,
these chat networks
didn't talk to each other.
AOL didn't talk to Yahoo
which didn't talk to ICQ,
and none of them
would talk to us.
AOL had the largest user base.
So we discussed the
possibility of adding code
to allow Messenger to log into
two servers simultaneously,
Microsoft's and AOL's, so that
users could see their Messenger
and AIM buddies on a
single list and talk
to AIM buddies via Messenger.
We called it "interop."
AIM's protocol was
known as OSCAR,
stood for acronym for Open
System for Communication
in Realtime.
It was undocumented.
So me and my mentor at the
time signed up for AIM accounts
and watched the AIM client talk
to the server using a network
monitor.
I saw the protocol
that AIM was using.
My mentor Chris had
figured out a large chunk
of OSCAR this way.
And after he left the
team, I picked up his work
and finished the job.
So, you know, did
AOL notice that there
were some odd messages heading
their way from Redmond?
Probably not.
They had tens of
millions of users.
And we were mimicking their
protocol reasonably well.
But I thought this little stunt
would be deemed too dubious
and excised from Messenger
before it shipped.
But management liked it.
So on July 22, 1999, Microsoft
entered the chat markets
with MSN Messenger Service
complete with a AOL interop.
No one had warned
AOL of our gambit.
And they weren't
happy with what we
termed our "unauthorized
interoperability."
Quickly, they blocked
Messenger from connecting
to their servers by veering
their protocol messages in ways
we hadn't anticipated.
Users who tried to contact
their AIM buddies from Messenger
would receive a pop-up
instant message saying,
"Use an authorized AOL client
at this link," with the URL.
But as long as Messenger sent
exactly the same protocol
messages to the AOL
servers, AOL wouldn't
be able to detect that
a user was on Messenger.
So I took the AIM
client and meticulously
checked for differences
in what it was sending
and then changed our client
to mimic it once again.
Messenger users received an
upgrade with this new fix.
And because this was the dial-up
days, the client was tiny.
It was literally 300 K. It
was not even a megabyte.
But AOL, again, caught on and
switched their protocol up.
We matched their client again,
pushed out another upgrade.
We went back and forth
at least a dozen times.
At one point, AOL
sneakily excluded users
logging on from Microsoft
headquarters IPs
from their changes so
that we would be unaware
that either Messenger users
were receiving an error message.
After an hour or two of
scratching our heads,
a team member sick at home
notified us that, yes,
she was getting disconnected.
And a shout-out
to Kara for doing
that amazing work [LAUGHS]
when we were all going crazy.
Microsoft and AOL were
both tech titans in 1999.
Soon, the press got
a hold of the story.
On July 24, the "New York
Times" printed "In Cyberspace,
Rivals Skirmish Over "Messaging.
"AOL kept blocking us," wrote
the paper of record, quote,
"but Microsoft
refused to roll over.
Late Friday, the
software giant said
that it revised its MSN
Messenger program to circumvent
America Online's roadblock.
Within hours, America Online
answered that challenge
with a new block."
[LAUGHTER]
It was like reading
about a wrestling
match in which I was the
mysterious masked challenger.
OK, so another quote.
This is from the great
20th century polymath Jacob
Aronofsky.
"Progress is the exploration
of our own error."
And I think anyone who's
been a software engineer sure
knows that.
So the messenger war was a rush.
Climbing into work every morning
to see whether the client still
worked with AOL was thrilling,
even if it usually wasn't.
When it wasn't working, I
looked through the reams
of protocol messages
to figure out
what had changed, fixed the
client, tried to get an update
out the same day.
I had no idea who my adversaries
were, but I'd been challenged,
and I wanted to win.
And our users cared, too,
and they wanted us to win.
And this was, you know, having
actual users on your side
at Microsoft and those days
was actually somewhat unusual.
[LAUGHING] So AOL tried
different tactics.
At one point, I thought
that they were identifying
the Microsoft client
because it wasn't
downloading the advertising
that the AOL client downloaded.
So I updated our client
to download it all
and throw it away.
AOL included mysterious
protocol messages
that didn't seem to affect
their client but broke ours.
So I fixed that.
One day, I came in
to see this embedded
in the messages from
the AOL server, "Hi.
-Mark."
It was a little
missive from engineer
to engineer, hidden from the
corporate media and PR worlds
that were arguing over us.
I felt solidarity with
him even though we
were on opposing sides.
In the press, AOL was
pushing propaganda
about how Microsoft was
behaving like an evil hacker
by asking for AOL passwords.
But this wasn't true.
But we were allowed
only to respond
through the PR department.
My team was sealed off,
but our code wasn't.
And then, one day, AOL
stopped blocking us.
It was strange to
encounter sudden silence
as though the enemy had abruptly
yielded the battlefield.
And while I wanted to
believe we had won,
I suspected AOL wouldn't
give up without a word.
And a week later, we
found that Messenger
had been blocked again.
But this time was different.
The AOL server was sending a
huge chunk of new gobbledygook
that I could not understand.
And it looked like this.
The first couple lines are the
standard AOL protocol header,
the 2A02779C.
This is all fairly
standard stuff.
But from these 90, 90, 90, 90,
onward, it was incomprehensible
and didn't bear any relation
to anything the AOL service had
sent their client or ours.
The vast expanse of
double zeros in the middle
was also mysterious,
since a bunch of zeros
couldn't contain much meaning.
Our client ignored it.
But the AOL client responded
to this gobbledygook
with a shorter version
of the same gobbledygook.
I didn't know what it was.
And it was maddening.
After staring at
it for half a day,
I went over to Jonathan,
a brilliant server
engineer on our team, and
asked what he thought.
And he looked at it for a
few minutes and he said,
this is code.
Specifically, well, that's code.
Actually, most of it's code.
But the most important part is
down here as you might guess.
It was actual x86 assembly code.
The repeated 90s
had tipped him off
because they signify
a no-op instruction
x86 assembler
telling the processor
to do nothing for one cycle.
So the pieces came together.
Normally, protocol messages
read as data, not as code.
But AOL's client had
a security bug in it.
It had a buffer overflow in it.
And, actually, let me
ask, how many people
know what a buffer overflow is?
I'm going to skip
over, oh, everyone.
We're going to skip over that.
Actually, for all the
viewers in TV land,
it basically means is
that you can run over
the edge of an
assigned spot in memory
and overwrite the program
code with whatever you want.
So they were overwriting
it with x86 assembler.
And they were controlling the
function of the AOL client.
It's a huge security hole.
And AOL knew about this
bug in their programming.
And now they were exploiting it.
The double zeros were filling up
space in the program's buffer.
And once it hit the
end of the buffer,
it overwrote the executable
code with the remainder
of the protocol message.
This is the new code
which caused the client
to look up a particular
configurable address in memory
and send it back to the server.
And this was tricky
and much trickier
than anything
they've done so far.
And it was a bit outside
the realm of fair play,
hacking into their own client
using an unfixed security
hole, a hole that our
client did not possess.
It was a "Rommel, you
magnificent bastard" moment.
And I was out of my depth.
Someone else at Microsoft--
I never found out who-- told
the press about the buffer
overflow, figuring that if
people knew that the AOL
client had a huge
security hole in it,
AOL would be forced
to patch their client
and would no longer
be able to exploit it.
So according to the security
expert Richard M. Smith,
a certain Phil Bucking
of Bucking Consulting
sent him an email,
alerting him to the buffer
overflow in the AOL client.
"Dear Mr. Smith,
I am a developer
who has been working on a
revolutionary new instant
messaging client that should
be released later this year.
Because of that, I
followed with interest
the battle between
AOL and Microsoft
and have been trying to
understand exactly what AOL
is doing to block
Microsoft and how Microsoft
is getting around the blocks.
Up until very recently, it's
been pretty standard stuff.
But now I fear AOL
has gone too far.
It appears that the AIM client
has a buffer overflow bug.
By itself, this may not
be the end of the world
as Microsoft has
surely had its share."
[LAUGHTER] Yes, yes.
"But AOL is now exploiting
their own buffer overflow bug
to help its efforts to block
MSN Instant Messenger."
So it's a bit
ham-fisted, I think.
The developer of a
revolutionary new app
takes sides in the
Microsoft-AOL war
without promoting his own app?
The email also includes
this actual trace.
This is from the
email, because I
don't have my notes from
it anymore, because those
were confidential.
But I can still have that.
And if Phil Bucking's
text and his name
weren't suspicious
enough, he'd also
sent the message from one
of Microsoft's computers
at a Microsoft IP.
[LAUGHTER]
The IP address showed
up in the email headers.
And Microsoft's
digital fingerprints
were all over the email.
Smith accused Microsoft
of sending the email,
and Microsoft fessed up.
The news story that emerged
covered Microsoft's attempt
to bad-mouth AOL under a
fake identity, an easier sell
than explaining the
buffer overflow.
People on various
security forums
ascertained that the
buffer overflow was real
and invade further against AOL.
But the press wasn't
paying attention.
The buffer overflow persisted
into several later versions
of AOL's client.
AOL never admitted a
thing, and the press never
did understand it.
So we gave up.
And I licked my wounds, and
I joined the server team.
The larger lesson
of the messenger war
was that the workings
of code were no longer
a private matter known
only to those steeped
in the law of computing.
They were increasingly
becoming public affairs
that impacted national
and even global events.
And, you know, certainly
coming in the wake of Cambridge
Analytica, it proved
more true than anything
even when I read this.
The chat wars were to me
a duel between a handful
of people within two
gargantuan companies.
And yet, they became a national
news story for a brief period.
Looking back, it was
the first inkling
I had that it wasn't
just computers
that were permeating all our
lives but the code itself.
And yet, few grasp code's
function and its impact,
something that is
still true today.
The ultimate outcome
of the conflict
resulted from buffer overflow
whose existence was never
agreed upon because neither
reporters nor the public
understood it.
So sometime after
I left Microsoft,
I met one of the AOL engineers
who had worked against me.
We had a huge laugh over it.
And I complimented him on
the genius of the buffer
overrun exploit, even
as I bemoaned my loss.
It had been a great game,
I said, and he agreed.
We were both dumbstruck
that we were still
to a very small number of
people who knew the real story
after all of these years.
So that's the buffer
overflow story.
The second section-- if you can
hold your questions to the end,
I was going to read two
more short segments that
relate to-- well,
the fact of the book
goes all over the place.
How many of you know "Dwarf
Fortress," by the way?
Just a couple?
OK, I'm not going to be speaking
about that today, although I
did think about
talking about it.
But I discussed
that in the book,
because I think it's a good
example of how computers can
and cannot model the world.
So this is a section called
"Truthtellers and Liars."
It begins with a
Charles Sanders Peirse
quote, "All that logic warrants
is a hope and not a belief."
So there is a type
of puzzle made
most famous by the
logician Raymond Smullyan
and by the movie
"Labyrinth" that involves
liars and truthtellers.
And how many of you know these
sorts of liar-truthteller logic
puzzles?
Yeah, OK, we'll
just skip over that.
I'll just give you a variant
that I gave to my daughter.
Let's say, we've got two doors.
And behind one is a
huge amount of money,
and behind the other is a shark.
I decided that the
lady or the tiger
was a bit of a relic
from an earlier era,
so I changed it
to money or shark,
which I thought was
very, very contemporary.
OK, so the writing on the doors;
on door one, "The shark is
in here;" door two,
"Both doors are lying."
Well, door two must
be lying, because it's
impossible to truthfully
say that you're a liar,
so door one must be
true, or else door two
would be telling the truth.
The shark is behind
door one, and the money
is behind door two.
I compulsively worked through
hundreds of these as a kid.
And I was fortunate my mother
stumbled on Smullyan's book
"Alice in Puzzle-land."
How many of you read
"Alice in Puzzle-land?"
I was going to say, there's
got to be at least a couple.
And that became my introduction
to the field of Boolean logic,
in liar-truthteller puzzles
and logical paradoxes.
Smullyan's use of Lewis Carroll
suited the truthteller puzzles
since, you know, Carroll
had been a logician himself.
And some of the
puzzles in these books
grew extraordinarily
ornate, requiring
multiple levels of inference.
Sometimes they didn't tell
you what one or another person
had said.
Sometimes "yes" and
"no" were replaced
with nonsense words like "bal"
and "da" that meant yes or no,
but you didn't know which.
There were even
abstruse puzzles that
attempted to explain Kurt
Godel's Incompleteness Theorem,
but it was above my
head at that age.
But one puzzle
genuinely irritated me.
And this is a simplified
version of it.
So a man is trying to figure
out which of two caskets
contain a portrait.
On the first portrait, we have,
"The portrait is not in here."
And the second casket said,
"Exactly one of these caskets
is telling the truth."
So where's the portrait?
Well, whether or not the second
casket is telling the truth,
the first casket must
not be, because it says,
"The portrait is not in here."
Either the second
casket is true,
and the first casket
is therefore false.
Or the second casket is false,
and thus the first casket
must be false as well,
or else the second casket
would be telling the truth.
In the puzzle, the man
also figures the portrait
is in the first casket.
He opens it up
and finds nothing.
The portrait's in
the second casket.
He is utterly baffled.
And so was I. And the
answer seemed indisputable
in this very simple puzzle.
So here's what Smullyan
wrote as an explanation.
"Without any information given
about the truth or falsity
of any of these sentences,
nor any information given
about the relation of
their truth values,
the sentences
could say anything,
and the object
could be anywhere.
Good heavens, I can take
any number of caskets
that I please and put
an object in one of them
and then write any inscriptions
at all on the lids,
and these sentences won't
convey any information."
I felt cheated.
I felt that Smullyan had
made an implicit promise
that he would be providing
logic puzzles that made sense.
But I grudgingly observed
the other puzzles explicitly
claimed that the rules
were being obeyed.
And in this puzzle, there
was no such guarantee.
The lesson was that
truth and falsity
are not absolute but
relative to a context.
Outside that context, statements
lose sense of meaning.
Without the guarantee that
rules are being followed,
we can never be sure that
our reasoning is valid.
And nowhere is that more
true than in the logical
and contextually isolated
world of computers.
So from there, I go on to
talk about bits themselves.
Bits are commonly represented
by the degree of voltage on--
in transistor.
And there's nothing true
or false on circuit boards
containing transistors-- the
binaries between the voltage
being on or off.
Off isn't actually zero
as I made sure to say.
And the binary isn't between
true or false or even 0 and 1.
No one is actually interested
in whether gates output
a voltage signal
except in as much
as that signal represents
something else.
And what such signals
represent in a computer
is an abstract notion of
logical truth and falsehood,
which is a notion imposed by us.
Truth and falsehood
are conceptions
that we apply to the presence
or absence of a signal
at a particular point
on a circuit board.
The binary
representation of truth
is so ubiquitous
that we chronically
[? complate ?] logical true
false and computational 1 0,
on off binaries.
A programming language permits
me to have a Boolean variable.
Let's call it is
this thing on, which
can be either true or false.
And the simplest representation
and most common representation
would be to use 0 for
false and 1 for true.
But what if with this
numerical representation
we run across a 2 or some
other number that's not 0 or 1?
We could declare those
numbers to be meaningless--
neither true nor false.
But we don't want a ternary
logic in which there are not
two, but three options--
true, false, and meaningless.
So in C the convention
is that 0 is false.
And any other number is true.
This representation appeals
to our common convention
of equating truth
with existence.
Falsehood is nothing--
absence, emptiness, is zero.
Truth is presence of
validity existence.
Anything other than zero
even a negative number--
for those of you who
use Microsoft H results
you know that it's
reversed in that way.
And 0 is actually the
standard success result--
something that
caused a lot of bugs
when people just
used to not sign on H
results thinking that
they were binary results.
A programmer is--
and I include myself
in this-- is
conditioned to treat
true and false as synonyms
for 1 and 0 respectively.
True and false become
the two possible values
for a single bit in
a two bit system.
It is two value system.
[LAUGHTER]
These truths and
falsehoods remain a purely
formal convention
even though the words
contain metaphysical
weight within them.
If I write God
exists equals true,
that obviously doesn't
cause God to exist.
Nor does it cause the
computer to think or believe
that God exists.
All it does is set a
signal somewhere deep
in the recesses of
a computer's memory.
That line of code,
however, suggests
more than just the changing
of signal on a circuit board.
Any meaning we assign
to true and false
besides the signals being
on or off is interpretation.
If I say God exists, I'm making
a claim about the real world.
When a program contains a
statement God exists equal one,
it merely indicates the
alteration of a signal.
So computers don't
understand the difference
between true and false.
Nor do they understand
what the concepts mean.
And if a computer is to gain any
grasp on truth as we understand
it, it will have to be someplace
other than in its bits.
And another quote
from Thomas Pynchon--
"Who claims truth,
truth abandons."
And there's a little
historical context.
The history of logic
has long wrestled
with the problem of getting
that true to mean more than one
or on--
the problem of getting true to
say something about the world.
The difficulty started
long before computers.
We may think that
we can patently
tell the difference between
a true and a false statement.
But outside of logic puzzles
pinning down this distinction
proves horrendously
vexing to the point
that both Western philosophers
like Sextus Empiricus
and Eastern philosophers
like Nagarjuna
question whether the truth
of anything could be known.
These concerns, which might seem
like philosophical navel gazing
became far more urgent
once formal logic
entered the picture.
The great logician
Alfred Tarski,
an influence on computer science
and artificial intelligence,
coined Convention T
as a minimal criterion
for the truth of the statement.
Here are two examples
of Convention T.
Actually how many of
you know convention T?
Not too many.
OK.
Logic's not in these days.
All it is is you put a
sentence in quotes like,
"The sky is blue."
The sky is blue is true if
and only if the sky is blue.
I am a jelly donut is true if
and only if I am a jelly donut.
And a great deal of
philosophical ink
has been spilled
on Convention T.
But I think most people will
agree that this criterion is
not especially helpful as a
practical guide to determining
the truth of a statement.
And yet we may even despair at
how little progress Convention
T seems to make over Aristotle's
definition of over 2000
years ago.
To say of what it is--
to say of what is that it is
not or of what is not that it is
is false.
While to say of what
it is that it is
and of what is not
that it is not is true.
Not so helpful.
OK.
Yeah.
But whatever truth
may be, we can
conclude that in order to
interact well with the world,
computers must be
able to distinguish
between true and false in
the same way as humans do.
"The inadequacies of
logicians' attempts
to collapse the difference
between a logical truth
and a worldly truth have
been made all too clear
in the computing age.
The mathematician and
phenomenologist Gian-Carlo Rota
put this bluntly.
"Mathematicians are
therefore mystified
by the spectacle of
philosophers pretending
to re-inject philosophical
sense into the language
of mathematical logic.
The fake philosophical
terminology
of mathematical logic
has misled philosophers
into believing that
mathematical logic
deals with the truth in
the philosophical sense.
But this is a mistake.
Mathematical logic
deals not with the truth
but only with the game of truth.
The snobbish symbol
dropping found nowadays
in philosophical
papers raises eyebrows
among mathematicians
like someone
paying his grocery bill
with Monopoly money."
Rota here echoes Plato's,
who was one of the first
to find that truth as
a practical matter--
a matter of action rather than
a pure theoretical abstraction.
And Paul Friedlander's summary--
"Truth in Plato's system is
always both reality of being
and correctness of
apprehension and assertion."
Or in William James's words--
"Truth happens to an idea.
It becomes true-- is
made true by events.
The troublesome gap is not
between logic and language,
between logic and reality.
Symbols and proofs cannot
close that gap on their own."
Finally, three quotes-- one--
Tarn Adams is actually the
author of "Dwarf Fortress."
"You activate bugs and little
parts of the code from eight,
six years ago where you just
didn't balance the numbers,
because it didn't matter."
And the great computer
scientist Alan Perlis--
"Every program is a part
of some other program
and really fits"-- something
that everyone in this room
I'm sure already knows.
And finally, this
is my daughter.
And this is something
she-- this is
a song she wrote, which I think
sums it up better than me.
"And errors can happen
to you and computers,
because you are a computer.
Go and do it.
Program yourself.
Just do it.
Explore your toes.
Explore your nose.
Explore everything
you have goes.
And if you don't
want to do that,
you can't even live, not even
houses, because houses are us."
All right.
That is what I wanted to end on.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I've thought
a lot in my life
about how a deep understanding
of computer science
shapes my worldview
and makes me think
of the world in
computational terms.
And at the same
time, I've thought
a lot about how kind of
similarly to what you're
saying that that's
insufficient to kind of bridge
the gap between conscious
reality or reality
in general and you know, physics
and math and all of that.
And I feel like in many
ways this computational way
of thinking about the
world is extremely useful
and at the same
time very clouding,
because it makes us
overreach in the way
that you were alluding
to in your last piece.
I was just wondering
whether you could elaborate
on your thoughts on that.
DAVID AUERBACH: Yeah, I
mean this is something
that I can speak about,
because I'm here,
which is that one of
the strangest things
was that as a
software engineer I
felt like I was
surrounded by people
who thought it was enough.
[LAUGHTER]
I thought there must be
something wrong with me,
because everybody else
seemed so definite.
And I feel like it's
just not working for me.
And honestly a large
part of the book
is me trying to elaborate on why
I was so dissatisfied with it,
which is one of the
reasons why I don't program
full time anymore.
And I had been--
I was a lit geek
from a young age.
And I like some of the
formal experimental books.
Like, there's a French
author, George Perec,
who wrote a book called "Life
A User's Manual," which is
Donald Knuth's favorite novel.
And everything is sort of
mathematically structured
by all sorts of
formal mechanisms.
And it's beautiful.
And I found out actually
in researching the book
that Perec had been writing
another project in which he
needed a 12 by 12 Graeco
Latin square in the late '60s.
And there had been
a paper written
on computationally
generating them,
because he couldn't
make one by hand.
And I think that--
was it Euclid or Euler who
thought that there didn't even
exist Graeco Latin squares
beyond a certain single digit
size-- but someone had written
a paper on computationally
generating them.
And the co-author
was Donald Knuth.
So Perec wrote to
Knuth back in the days
before Knuth was quite the
household name that he is today
and got a two 12 by 12 square.
So I love that
point of connection.
And that, I think, was
one of the things that
helped keep me
going and thinking,
OK, there is room to try to
merge these two approaches,
because for many years, I did
feel like my mind was on two
parallel tracks, because I
was doing some literature
stuff in the background.
And then this was my job.
And I did--
I enjoyed it a lot.
But but each one I
think felt incomplete.
And I couldn't see how to
sort of draw them together
in any way.
And for many years, I did seem
to be quite separate pieces,
because a lot of the literature
and philosophy I studied
was resolutely non-quantitative
and even non-logical.
And as Gian-Carlo
Rota points out,
the attempts to integrate
them were very ham fisted.
That continues even to this day.
One of the things
I'm working on now
is Shakespearean authorship
attribution using machine
learning methods.
And it's not-- this is basically
the plot of T statistics
of words mapped
against frequencies.
And because these
machine learning models--
these were using decision trees
random forests and a method
called [? mirror ?]
shrunken centroid.
But because the models
were all opaque,
the internal results
of the decision trees
weren't presented.
I had to rip the models apart
to sort of figure out actually
how is this
attribution being made.
And it seems like
they were just being
made on the basis of a
handful of very popular words.
Like, and is used
very frequently
by authors who aren't
Shakespeare and is not
used very frequently by
Shakespeare comparatively
on a consistent basis.
But if you don't actually
have this breakdown,
it can look very impressive.
So I think there's still a lack
of good understanding as far as
how you draw these
things together.
And part of that is
because of the problems
with semantic understanding
that computers still have.
I was always
something of a skeptic
when it came to semantic
AI, good old fashioned AI.
And I guess I felt a little
vindicated now that the much--
the neural nets and other
supervised training--
learning techniques-- sub--
symbolic techniques
were sort of pooh
poohed in the late 20th century
and the mid-20th century
in particular.
But once you have enough
data, suddenly they
go way past anything that
symbolic AI has accomplished.
So that's sort of
a rambling answer.
And I guess the short
answer is that, yeah--
is that I treat it
at great length in--
[LAUGHTER]
--the book.
Would anyone else like to
ask anything whatsoever?
AUDIENCE: So the two
excerpts you read were--
one of them was very narrative.
And the other one was very--
what's the word-- expository.
And what's the balance that
you were trying to strike?
And like, what is the book like?
Is it a lot of
narrative structure?
Is it a lot of exposition?
Do you like munch them together?
DAVID AUERBACH: Yeah,
well hopefully they--
I skipped over the transition.
I tried to have it be both.
I mean, I was
encouraged-- apparently--
so I am naturally sort
of a top down writer.
So if I had just gone at
it, it might have been
more directly philosophical.
But a lot of people
said, no, no, no, David.
You should make
it more personal.
And some of the
stories are good.
But I tried to-- but there's
plenty of the parts of my life
that I left out, because I
thought they were completely
boring or irrelevant.
So to the extent that
I talk about my life
it is always in the service
of the larger points.
And the balance is I don't--
it's hard to say.
I don't know what
the balance is.
Would you say
it's-- is it 50/50?
I guess my point,
though, is that having
read books of both sorts I
think that you actually do
need both pieces--
that I actually-- I--
after many years looking at
politics but also arguments
of other forms it does seem
that stories are actually
better at convincing people
than arguments per se.
And so crafting
a narrative story
that illustrates a point in a
more concrete and visceral way
can actually be more effective
than a deductive argument
in which you argue
from first principles,
because there's usually some
assumption made in there
or some prior if
you're a Bayesian
that if you don't agree on,
you'll just say no, no, no,
this is completely invalid.
I'm not going to follow it.
But you know, you got a story.
And the thread of narrative
is carrying you through.
That's sort of my
thinking about it.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: I'm just
wondering if I
could ask you about your
process writing this book.
I know you said in the Q&A
how, like, you ended up
finding narrative themes
that you might not
have intended initially.
Like, how was the
process in general?
DAVID AUERBACH: Oh, my God.
You read the Q&A. Oh, my God.
OK.
Well, oh, boy.
Let me say something
that I haven't already.
The process-- well,
actually to return
to the previous
question, I did start off
by writing some pretty
theoretical stuff.
And I think my editor sort of
reacted with horror saying--
there was an entire--
[LAUGHTER]
There was an entire--
back in the day I did
compiler research.
I loved working on
compilers, because it
was like-- it's like, oh,
it puts everything together.
And I had a chapter on
compilers and compilers
as illustrating the structure
of abstraction layers
and computers.
That chapter got cut.
And it got replaced with
a chapter on my daughter.
[LAUGHTER]
And you know, what can I say?
Maybe it will go
into the next book.
But so it was a matter
of approximation.
And it was a way of--
I had some existing
pieces that I'd written.
There is one in particular
called the "The Stupidity
of Computers" for n+1 that
I think did provide the germ
for this.
And what I set out wanting to
do was to write something that
wasn't necessarily for
a technical audience
although I tried
very hard to make it
so that someone technical
would read it and say,
OK, this person
speaks my language,
because whenever I'd
written for various venues
I would often speak to a
software engineer there.
And they'd say, oh, my God.
I'm so glad you're
writing for us.
You actually
understand computers.
And I-- this happened
enough that I was like, OK,
there's a gap here in terms
of people do not want to read
another abstract critique of
how the post-modern structure
of computation is altering
the nature of subjectivity
in the postmodern age-- you
know, something like that--
you know, that being
able to talk about this
in which the particulars of the
computer science matter is I
think something that actually
is very useful and helpful.
And so I wanted to
sort of communicate
that toolset as well as
some greater reflections
on that toolset--
things that I didn't
know when I even--
in college but sort of had come
to from thinking about them.
I'll tell you I was a columnist
for Slate for some years.
And one of these shockingly--
well, there were two columns--
actually there
were three columns
that I wrote that were
incredibly surprisingly
popular.
One was on the amazing
kids game Robot Odyssey.
How many people here ever
played Robot Odyssey?
The hardest computer
game-- it was--
you had to use logic
gates to program robots.
This was made for the
Apple II in, like, 1984.
It is the hardest computer
game I ever played.
I didn't solve it
until I was in college,
because what it asks you to
do with logic gates is so damn
abstract.
And I didn't possess
those skills back then.
That one was a huge hit.
A piece on Roko's
basilisk was a huge hit,
because everybody
loves Roko's basilisk.
And if you don't know
about Roko's basilisk,
you should look it up.
And the third one was about
Wittgenstein and philosophy
of language and how it
related to computer science
and how it had helped me
understand some of the things
I was talking about.
And so in some ways,
those three pieces
understanding that computers
were now touching everyday life
and that the best way
of understanding this
was to both have a grasp
of bits and the structures
of computing, as well as the
larger picture of what they
meant in terms of
everyday living
was something that I
wanted to communicate.
And then I thought I could
hopefully have something
useful to contribute on.
I don't know.
Does that answer your question?
Thanks for reading
the Q&A. I think
I also said that it was the
hardest thing I'd ever done.
And I still agree with that.
It was not-- writing is hard.
I don't recommend it to
anyone who absolutely
doesn't need to do it.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks for coming.
I look forward to
reading the book.
DAVID AUERBACH: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I don't know if
you answered this in the book.
But there's been a lot of talk
last few years about teaching
computational thinking
to more and more people
or more simplistically teaching
programming to everyone.
And I'm curious what you think--
whether this is a good thing.
Or is it being overhyped?
DAVID AUERBACH: I mean,
I guess it can be both.
There's always a hype.
There's always hype
around something or other.
It's like, you can
say to some extent,
oh it's teaching kids about
big data and a good thing
or overhyped.
Well, yes, it's good to
know about those things.
But the words big data
may make you think,
oh, well, let's not
teach it like that.
And I think everyone can
certainly benefit from knowing
how code works just in the way
that I think they're going--
people should-- can benefit from
knowing a bit about how machine
learning models work and
how they can and can't--
what they can and can't do.
At the same time, you
know, marketing it
as, oh, this is going to be
of practical usage to you
and you should definitely
become a programmer
or something like that I
don't think is necessary.
I think that it would be better
to propose this as, yes, this
is fundamental knowledge
in the same way
that mathematics is logic--
having some base even
theoretical appreciation
of what an algorithm is,
how an algorithm can work.
Maybe this is because I found
this stuff really interesting.
I don't know.
We recently picked up a
book for my seven-year-old--
a mathematics book
for a 7-year-old
that was recommended to
us by someone or other.
And they said, yeah, yeah,
this is great for like,
really getting
your kid into math.
And it was written
in [? LaTeX. ?]
And I said, OK, good sign.
But I started reading the
problems, like, oh, my God.
There's group theory
for seven-year-olds.
I was like, this is insane.
I was like, this
is very impressive.
But I literally--
I'm-- the number of kids
who can absorb this level
of abstraction, because
it was like, OK, well,
let's say you have beads on a
chain that alternate between
these three types of beads,
what is the 493rd bead?
I was like for a seven-year-old?
It's like, all right.
So I think it's a good thing.
I think that unfortunately,
especially ed tech being
the way that it
is, there's reason
to worry whether the right
things are being taught,
you know?
If you just teach people
how to design a clock
and put it up on a screen,
that's interesting.
I mean, it will get you
some appreciation and use.
But I think that
putting it into context
can be useful as
well, just this--
I mean, it would be as if you
only did like arithmetic word
problems in your entire
time at school, you know,
instead of going on to
algebra and calculus.
I don't know.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DAVID AUERBACH: OK.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
a [INAUDIBLE] Logo
example before.
And I wonder what
you think about
like this educational
programming things--
where we're going and what
would be the future of Logo
we're teaching?
DAVID AUERBACH: I don't know.
I mean, I look at Scratch.
And I have such mixed
feelings about it,
because on the one
hand, it's great to have
the notion of
imperative language
and functional abstraction.
But on the other hand,
it's like, they are talking
about recursion, you know.
Where are the-- that I feel like
to some extent there's some--
I do feel that you
could introduce
some of these concepts-- some
of the higher order concepts
in a cool way earlier on.
But at the same time I--
you know, the fact that the
kids are doing them is good.
And I mean I've seen
other computer games--
I've seen other,
like, kids games
that work on similar principles.
But I think to some
extent, you know,
it doesn't necessarily have to
take the form of programming
per se as much as
it is a certain form
of algorithmic abstraction.
And it doesn't necessarily
require programming so much
as learning the
nature of how data
structures and certain
algorithms can fit together.
And I'm saying that vaguely,
because I'm just thinking back
to the various things I did
when I was a kid that gave me
an appreciation.
You know, I think Truth Teller
and Logic Polls are great
as well.
And there are probably other
forms of puzzles that I
haven't--
that I'd never have played
that would be great as well.
And I think that--
well, we're all here at Google.
But if some of us
worked on trying
to figure out what
those are, that
would be wonderful, as well.
There was a puzzle
game I played recently
called Stephen's Sausage Roll.
Does anyone know that?
It is the hardest
puzzle game I've
played in many, many years.
And I felt it training my
brain quite well in terms of--
I mean, it is--
you can see how it was
very heavily influenced
by abstract algebra.
But it translates those
concepts into applications
within this game so that
you aren't doing, you know,
purely abstract exercises.
But you're actually executing
in a vaguely algorithmic manner.
So I hope there's
more of that honestly.
I think there's a lot
of room for improvement.
Certainly, you know, I look at--
actually it's
interesting, you know.
My daughter's learning chess.
And I feel like in some
ways chess tutelage
has been developed very
well, because the levels
of abstraction you treat
[? and trust ?] sort of go up
that ladder like that.
And it's because you have
such an established context
that it's helpful.
So in some ways, I would
say that learning chess
may actually be better for
you than learning Scratch.
I don't know.
AUDIENCE: In chess,
it really gets better.
I mean, like he beats me
in chess at this point.
DAVID AUERBACH: Yeah,
I mean there's a real--
you know.
What?
I was six years old.
And I had an Apple IIe
with a monochrome monitor.
But here you have--
you can draw shapes.
And that was cool enough for me.
I mean and I have a
short attention span
and need lots of stimulation.
So I don't think kids
would hate it today.
AUDIENCE: I try to replace
[INAUDIBLE] with JavaScript
and explain, like, to my son how
to draw with the shapes and--
DAVID AUERBACH: With JavaScript?
Oh, you're just
torturing him now.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: He didn't
seem very interested.
So--
DAVID AUERBACH: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: He didn't
seem that interested.
DAVID AUERBACH: That's
because it's JavaScript.
[LAUGHTER]
Try Python at least,
you know, or APL.
Maybe he'll like the cool
little, like, you know,
the symbols.
I don't know.
[LAUGHTER]
Sorry.
If I had been introduced to
JavaScript when I was six,
I probably wouldn't
be a programmer.
So-- does someone else
have a question back there?
Peter, you must have a question
and give me a hard time.
AUDIENCE: --too much
weight on logic and reason?
DAVID AUERBACH: Do I what?
AUDIENCE: Worry that
you put too much weight
on logic and reason.
DAVID AUERBACH: Didn't
I just criticize it?
AUDIENCE: Well, yes, but
there was a lot of philosophy
and logic in there.
I mean, the
background experience
there is the discovery
that winning an argument
doesn't make you right.
DAVID AUERBACH: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So--
DAVID AUERBACH: Well,
I mean, to some extent
I was hoping to play
to this audience.
I wouldn't have
read that section
to an audience of lit majors.
But this is presumably what
folks here do all the time.
And you know, maybe software
engineers have changed.
But I feel that the impulse to
quantify and regiment things
logically is still pretty
strong amongst software
engineers and other sorts
of engineers and scientists.
And so I think it's
worth exploring.
And I think that the
stuff I talk about still
underpins a lot of arguments.
I think it even--
you know, if you look at--
you can see it--
I guess if I were talking to
an audience of statisticians,
I'd probably be talking about
Bayesianism and frequentists.
And you could come
up and ask me,
do you think you place too
much emphasis on statistics?
And it's like, well, you
know, it's everywhere.
So the world may place
too much emphasis on it.
But--
AUDIENCE: Do you think software
engineers actually believe
in truth in their programs?
DAVID AUERBACH: No, no,
no, I mean, that's a--
what do I think software
engineers believe?
I think that software
engineers have
a tendency towards reifying
contingent categories
as literal and permanent.
For example, these four
personality tests--
maybe people don't like--
maybe people don't
go for Myers Briggs.
But you know apparently
we subject a lot of people
to classifying people
into four colors--
green, blue, gold, and orange.
And apparently most people
turn out to be greens.
So if this is something that
we all take seriously here
at Google, I would say--
well, I know you don't
take it seriously, Peter.
But would you argue that most
people take it seriously here?
AUDIENCE: I can't tell.
DAVID AUERBACH: OK.
My experience was that they do.
AUDIENCE: It's easy
to do over weight
what shows up on
weird mail threads
or in fact, any
mail thread, right?
DAVID AUERBACH: This
is just from talking--
AUDIENCE: --what people believe.
DAVID AUERBACH: This was
just talking to people.
I mean, I didn't read mail
threads when I was back here.
[LAUGHTER]
--seemed healthy.
AUDIENCE: Well, if this were
address a statistical group,
we would argue about your
sampling procedures, right?
DAVID AUERBACH: We could.
But don't you think you're
putting too much emphasis
on statistics?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: No, I think that's
the only way to truth.
DAVID AUERBACH: Well,
so there you go.
Perhaps overweighing the logical
truth in that definition--
AUDIENCE: I have what I think
is a very relevant question.
I was wondering
if you could talk
about what it's like to
write for and be criticized
by programmers on the internet.
DAVID AUERBACH: Yeah,
I mean, I'll be honest
and say people were
actually really nice.
I think-- and this is--
it sort of reinforced that
a lot of the feedback was,
oh, my God.
Finally someone who
knows about coding.
So I would say if
anything I was spoiled,
because I think that there's
not a lot of technical knowledge
on display at least in these
so-called popular press
or you know that I wouldn't
say I've gotten a lot of flack.
But in general, I
think that if anything,
I detected that there was
a certain frustration.
And I mean this is
frustration of sort
of getting writ
large at this point,
because you have a
larger cultural clash.
And this is something
that I've seen
being involved in like
the New York writing scene
and how much resentment
or at least loathing there
is towards the Silicon Valley
and tech people of all stripes.
And this can extend to
an ontological critique
that anyone in
programming must therefore
be an awful evil positivist,
which again, yeah, Peter,
you're right.
They aren't.
But you know, there
are lots of big names
who speak for
technical companies who
certainly qualify more on the
positivist side of things.
And there's a lot of unjustified
anger towards them, which
I think is based in ignorance.
I also think that,
yes, the worldview
could do with some intelligent
critiques rather than
ignorant critiques
that just cause them
to double down and think
that you know maybe we
should go back to
Ayn Rand, because she
was right after all.
I don't know.
Is that-- how's
that for an answer?
I mean, it's a culture clash.
It really is.
But and I guess
the thing is is I
have an affection for
both sides I suppose,
as well as frustration with
perhaps closed mindedness
that occurs of which I have my
own variants of it, you know.
Am I going to sit
here and tell you
that you should Jacques Derrida?
Hell no.
Am I going to tell you that
you should sit here and read--
I don't know Denis Diderot?
Yes.
So you know, there's
stuff to be gained.
But unfortunately
what rises to the top
is not always the best stuff.
AUDIENCE: You mention that
writing is very hard work.
And you wouldn't
recommend it to anyone.
So do you plan to
continue writing?
And will it be on
a similar topic?
DAVID AUERBACH: Yeah,
I have a problem.
Yeah, I mean it's--
you do it if you can't
do anything else.
I mean there's a Thomas
Mann quote where he said,
a writer is someone for
whom writing is harder
than it is for anyone else.
And I don't think--
I don't know that that's
true for all writers.
But it's certainly true for me.
And I just-- it
scratches some itch.
And you try to do it so that
you hopefully are serving
some greater purpose with it.
But that's the sort of
question that can make you
very, very self-conscious
in a hurry.
But I do plan to continue it.
I'm writing a young
adult novel right
now to get a complete
break from this,
because I didn't want to
write about myself anymore.
But yes.
I have more to say
about computers.
And hopefully, that'll be
in coming in the short term.
AUDIENCE: What is short term?
DAVID AUERBACH: Oh, boy.
Knowing life-- I mean, God.
You know, life cycles of
books are much slower.
So it depends if--
how-- next few years I hope.
I hope sooner if the
publishing industry
decides to speed up its cycles.
But I mean there was
like a year turnaround
after finishing this before
it actually came out.
So it's-- I do miss the
rapid release cycles of, hey,
I just [INAUDIBLE] this fix.
Let's push it out.
All right.
Good night.
If I could do that with
a book, that'd be great.
That's why I still
blog sometimes
just because being able to
write something and actually
put it out there for consumption
the same day is amazing.
And one of my most popular
pieces in the last year I
actually went through that.
And I had-- which was my
explanation of the finale
of "Twin Peaks--
The Return," which I wrote in
a couple of days, posted it.
And apparently a lot
of people really wanted
answers, because overnight
I get like literally
like 10,000 times more
traffic than my little blog
has ever seen before.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I agree.
I watched like five episodes.
And then I felt like it
doesn't make any sense.
Like, there's like
horrible things.
I didn't continue.
But then I was curious.
DAVID AUERBACH: I mean, what
I always told people-- look,
if you're not enjoying it moment
to moment, don't watch it.
You won't-- it's not worth it.
But at the end of it, I
did want to know more.
So anyway, thank you
very much, everybody.
It's been great.
It's been fun.
[APPLAUSE]